un bon soir violaine guérin merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
tout d'abord une première réaction sur
ces chiffres
vous êtes inquiète comment vous
définiriez la situation aujourd'hui
bonsoir et merci de m'accueillir je
donnais des problèmes de connections on
ne peut pas te voir te voir je dois
aussi vous dire tout de suite que je
n'ai aucun conflit d'intérêts quand je
prends la parole pour répondre à votre
question nous sommes en train de tester
à tout va en indication clinique il ya
un court-circuitage total des médecins
généralistes qui fait que la population
qui est extrêmement stressé par l'eba
nancy perd at il se précipite dans les
laboratoires et nous avons aujourd'hui
un nombre de tests complètement démesuré
par rapport à la réalité de la situation
et un nombre de textes qu'on aurait bien
aimé avoir au mois de mars au mois
d'avril on a des gestes qui ne sont pas
toujours fiables puisque vous avez sans
doute entendu qui expliquait que quand
il a essayé de vaincre et action avec
des tests positifs voulait confirmer
cette positivité en fonction de
l'origine des tests il y avait entre 25
et 40% de tests faux positifs donc face
déjà que c'est un premier élément
et deuxièmement quand vous présentez
même votre introduction il faut faire
attention de faire la différence entre
avoir un test positif et avoir la
maladie parce qu' énormément de gens
sont asymptomatiques
et donc on ne peut pas vraiment dire que
ce sont des cas pathologiques en fait ça
c'est important parce que si on avait
fait des tests au moins deux marteaux
mois d'avril on aurait eu probablement
plus de cent mille tests positifs à
cette époque-là par jour donc
aujourd'hui le nombre de textes n'est
pas inquiétant mais on fait extrêmement
peur
alors c'est vrai que c'est pas rassurant
que je l'admirais ce que vous nous dites
parce qu'on
nous annonce même des chiffres
importants vous nous expliquer
effectivement que cette stratégie de
dépistage ne fonctionne pas on est à
dire peut-être tous rendus compte si on
a eu à faire des tests aujourd'hui
clairement comment on s'en sort bien
écoutez il faut que la population
comprenne que elle doit passer par son
médecin généraliste qui décidera si
c'est opportun ou pas de faire les
textes parce qu'aujourd'hui en plus ça
nous empêche complètement de travailler
sur le terrain puisque les laboratoires
sont complètement emboliser moi j'ai
passé ma semaine là à voir des patients
qu'ils viennent pour des pathologies
compact faire leur examen biologique
parce que il n'ya 3 4 heures de queue
sur sur les laboratoires
donc c'est très important ne vous faites
pas testé sans avoir un avis médical ça
n'a aucun sens de toute façon de faire
un test en étant totalement atteint
automatique ou pour voir si parce que de
toute façon pour voir si et bien 48
heures après on peut très bien avoir
être en contact avec quelqu'un donc
c'est faut faire des sets de façon avec
des indications cliniques tout à fait
pertinente
donc aujourd'hui également sur le
terrain les médecins généralistes ou les
médecins spécialistes comme moi on ne
voit pas de cas graves de co vides la
plupart des personnes d'ailleurs n'ont
même pas vu de copie de patient malade
depuis plusieurs mois donc il faut se
méfier parce que on peut avoir un sens
positif aussi et avoir tout à fait autre
chose au niveau symptomatique
il y à une telle terreur que les gens
des symptômes de stress qui ne
correspond pas du tout à la maladie il y
a des gens qui sont déprimés qu'ils ont
des complications du port du masque tout
à fait
c'est un petit peu même être graves moi
j'ai vu bon d acné satisfaction c'était
un programme d'une tartine au coccyx de
la fac c'est beaucoup plus grave
cette semaine j'ai vu une femme enceinte
en hypoxie parce que c'était pas du tout
opportun pour elle de porter un mac
alors qu'il n'y a aucune justification
médicale
donc on est dans un an quelque chose de
tout à fait irrationnel et notre rôle je
pense est médecin et de rassurer les
patients et de l'or vraiment de les
conseiller de contacter leur médecin
celui qui les connaît keller référent
ils ont des questions qu'ils ont des
symptômes et qu'il soit examiné ausculté
équipe alc passe pas faire des bilans
biologiques comme fable façon tout à
fait irrationnel
violaine des dernières questions demain
conseil de défense emmanuel macron on
nous promet des annonces il nous parle
notamment de territorialité à quoi vous
vous attendez est-ce qu'on doit crainte
de nouveau confinement notamment et bien
écoutez sur le plan sanitaire il n'y a
aucune justification à plat d'abord
parce que je rappelle qu'il ya des
traitements disponibles impact très fort
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne veut pas
entendre en france mais il ya énormément
de publication et vous savez très bien
aussi que le collectif les tons les
médecins à prescrire à prêter quand
c'était accessible
les médecins nous nous sommes prêtés
avec le protocole et groklaw kimasi trop
me signer on a une publication
internationale sur le sujet donc il y à
des traitements sacrée cote qui ne ce
justicier aucunement toutes les mesures
là tout à fait liberticide donc on n'est
plus dans un problème de de santé
publique on est dans un problème
politique
donc on est extrêmement inquiète de ce
qui se passe on souhaite que le conseil
scientifique que toutes les personnes
qui ont des conflits d'intérêts et je
peux vous dire que la liste est
extrêmement longue dans le conseil
scientifique sorte ce concept simply
fixé on veut vraiment faire de la santé
publique et pas de la politique
donc aujourd'hui coûté tout est possible
dans les annonces demain il ya des
choses tout à fait irrationnel et bon
bah on va attendre demain mais en tout
cas par rapport à vos auditeurs qui sont
des patients potentiels ou qui ont des
personnes âgées autour d'elle ou des
enfants
voilà on veut vous ratures et ça c'est
très important
vous avez entendu que le il ya beaucoup
de mythes actions de ce virus qui l'est
nettement moins pathogène nettement
moins positif
donc s'il ya des doutes il ya des
questions consulter vos médecins
généralistes qu'il vous examine qui
prescrivent les les examens
complémentaires qui sont nécessaires et
je rappelle à mes confrères dont
beaucoup aussi son bord peur parce que
il ya des menaces des conseils de
l'ordre il ya des on a des mails tous
les jours de la direction générale de la
santé fait vraiment de la clinique vous
savez traiter une grippe vous savez
traiter une pneumonie
appliquez de la médecine vraiment
clinicienne et et et voiliers confiance
dans vos capacité d'accompagner les
passions comme on le fait d'habitude
merci violaine vers un médecin des
membres du collectif laissons-les
médecin prescrit